en ce début d'année 2010 9 le venezuela
traverse la pire crise économique de son
histoire des tensions politiques agite
également le pays qui voit émerger un
inconnu
tout juste élu président du parlement
wang wei d'eau il est rapidement reconnu
par les principaux pays occidentaux
comme président du venezuela
la chine la russie ou encore l'iran
continuent pour leur part de soutenir
nicolás maduro
fin janvier des sanctions américaines
sévère frappe le pays interdit de
quitter le territoire
why do se rend tout de même en colombie
en février avant de se lancer dans une
tournée en amérique latine afin de
rallier de nouveaux dirigeants à sa
cause de son côté nicholas maduro
dénonce le 30 avril 2019 un coup d'état
instiguée par son opposant ce dernier
échoue les pourparlers entre pouvoir et
opposition sont au point mort durant
l'été 2010 neuf notamment en raison du
durcissement des sanctions de washington
la perspective d'un conflit armé prend
peu à peu de l'ampleur à la suite d'une
manoeuvre de la maison blanche visant à
déstabiliser caracas cependant le
président du parlement peine de plus en
plus à mobiliser dans son pays malgré le
soutien d'alliés étrangers
la pandémie de kobe 19 va renforcer cet
effritement du mouvement de contestation
en mai nicolás maduro affirme avoir
déjoué une nouvelle tentative de coup
d'état
il y voit l'oeuvre de son adversaire
gouaille d'eau et l'ombre de washington
dans une opération aux circonstances
troubles le 26 mai dernier wang wei
d'opare officiellement son titre de
président du parlement durant l'été
l'opposition décident de boycotter les
législatives du mois de décembre et
lance une consultation populaire
concurrentes
le fait que les crises politiques et
économiques ne sont toujours pas résolus
pousse chaque jour un peu plus le pays
vers la bim